spektakulärer einbruch heute nacht in
leipzig mitten in leipzig mitten in der
city in das juweliergeschäft bringt man
und lagen her dass die bilder aus der
nacht von dort wie gesagt mitten aus der
stadt viertel vor drei ist das passiert
eher daran die einbrecher mit einem auto
dort gegen das sicherheits rolltor dort
eine eingangstür wumms rein und sind
dann die polizei sagt mit einem
hammerähnlichen gegenstand reihen haben
da noch die eingangstür zusammen
geschlagen die scheiben zerstört rezai
war natürlich wenige minuten nach dem
überfall am tatort aber bisher keine
spur und das besondere kommt jetzt an
diesem einbruch mit dem auto sie hören
hier noch die alarmanlage alles schon
passiert genau vor einem jahr nämlich
april 20 21 von da stammen diese bilder
offenbar organisierte kriminalität
damals eine bande auch mit dem autor ein
in dieses juweliergeschäft und damals
fette beute gemacht nämlich in
millionenhöhe schmuck und luxusuhren
ausgeräumten teil davon konnte später in
polen sichergestellt werden aber bei
weitem nicht alles auch damals die täter
entkommen also innerhalb so kurzer zeit
der zweite heftige einbruch dort mitten
in der leipziger city in dieses genau
dieses juweliergeschäft also reportage
rum nußbaum ist vor ort mit ihm wollen
wir darüber sprechen kann das eigentlich
zufall sein warum oder finden die
behörden die polizei da jetzt schon
einige parallelen zwischen dem vorfall
aus dem letzten jahr und dem einbruch
jetzt bei der polizei ist es wirklich so
dass er gerade die ermittlungen anlaufen
die können schon sagen dass es wohl
keinen zusammenhang mit dem einbruch vom
letzten jahr gab zumindest nicht zu
diesen tätern denn ihr habt es ja gesagt
fünf tatverdächtige konnten damals in
polen festgenommen werden nur drei tage
nach dem einbruch und die sitzen wohl
auch immer noch in haft allerdings ist
die kommunikation mit den behörden in
polen und es sind schwierig sagt um uns
die polizei in leipzig und deswegen man
spricht man vermutet ist zumindest zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt von trittbrettfahrern
das geschäft liegt natürlich optimal
mitten in der city von leipzig nach
245 ist dann natürlich auch nichts los
man sieht hier der kameramann könnte ein
bisschen schwenken darf man eigentlich
nur ein bisschen anlauf nehmen muss von
der linken seite mit dem auto direkt in
das rolltor so wie beim letzten mal wir
stehen zwar direkt vor mir ein paar
bänke die das abhalten könnten aber ja
immer noch genug anlauf um das zu
kriegen es gibt noch einen weiteren
juwelier direkt um die ecke der ist aber
in einer passage gelegen da kommst du
mit so einem auto nicht ran und könnte
es nicht diesen versuch unternehmen das
rolltor zu öffnen inzwischen gibt es
auch erste hinweise zu den tätern es
sollen wieder wie im letzten jahr drei
täter gewesen sein dunkel gekleidet nach
zeugenaussagen und auch nach auswertung
der überwachungskamera dunkel gekleidet
dunkle hautfarbe wohl einer der täter
trug einen hut mit krempe und das tat
auto soll in diesem jahr wieder
dunkelblau gewesen sein wie im letzten
jahr wohl ein vw passat und der soll
auch wie im letzten jahr diese
parallelen sind unglaublich zwei tage
zuvor im süden von leipzig gestohlen
worden sein zumindest ist das jetzt der
erste verdacht und danach wird gefahndet
also doch etliche parallelen zwischen
diesen beiden taten diesen beiden
einbrüchen innerhalb eines guten jahres
strom jetzt ist das eine absolute
albtraum jahr für den eigentümer dieses
juweliergeschäftes dort mitten in der
stadt was hörst du von dort aus dem
geschäft und vor allen dingen auch wie
wird man sich das schützen also plant
man jetzt möglicherweise der poller
aufzustellen direkt vor dem geschäft
wir haben kurz denen der boutique
besitzer so heißt es sehr der store
manager sozusagen gesprochen er ist
natürlich fährt mit nerven wieder dieser
arbeit allerdings dass die gute
nachricht es wurde nichts gestohlen im
letzten jahr wieder wurde wurde über
eine million euro schaden angerichtet
stehlschaden und diesmal ist wohl nichts
verschwunden er hat offensichtlich der
sicherheitsvorkehrungen getroffen und
hatte auch vor direkt vor dem
ladeneingang einen poller errichten zu
lassen aber es ist nur ein fußgängerzone
da hat wohl nach seinen angaben die
stadt gesagt nein das können wir nicht
machen das wird zu einem internet und
könnte hier fußgänger gefährden zu einem
stolperstein werden aber vielleicht
jetzt nach diesem zweiten einbruch
innerhalb von gut einem jahr wäre das
eine überlegung um das zu sichern
es waren vier herzlichen dank deiner
informationen aus leipzig dort zum
zweiten
mal in ein juweliergeschäft eingebrochen
im auto rein der schmuck ist raus danke
[Musik]